MICHALE FEE: Today,
we're going to finish up
with recurrent neural networks.
So as you remember, we've
been talking about the case
where we have a layer of
neurons in which we have
recurrent connections
between neurons in the output
layer of our network.
And we've been developing
the mathematical tools
to describe the behavior
of these networks
and describe how they
respond to their inputs.
And we've been talking about the
different kinds of computations
that recurrent neural
networks can perform.
So you may recall that we
started talking about--
we introduced the
math or the concept
of how to study
recurrent neural networks
by looking at the
simplest recurrent
network that has a single--
it's a single neuron with a
recurrent connection called
an autapse.
A recurrent connection
has a strength lambda.
And we can write down--
let's see.
So we can write
down the equation
for this, the response
of this neuron,
without a recurrent
connection as tau dv dt equals
minus v. The minus v is
essentially a leak term,
so that if you put
input into the neuron,
the response of the neuron
jumps up and then decays
exponentially in
response to an input, h.
If we have a recurrent
connection lambda,
then there's an additional
input to the neuron
that's proportional to the
firing rate of the neuron.
We can rewrite that
equation now as tau dv
dt equals minus quantity
one minus lambda times
v plus the input.
And the behavior of this
simple recurrent neural network
depends strongly on the
value of this coefficient one
minus lambda.
And we've talked about
three different cases.
We've talked about case where
lambda is less than one,
where lambda is equal to one--
in which case, this
coefficient is zero--
and when lambda is
greater than one.
So let's look at those three
cases again for this equation.
So when lambda is
less than one, you
can see that this quantity
right here, this coefficient
in front of the v is negative.
And what that means is that
the firing rate of this neuron
relaxes exponentially
toward some h infinity--
sorry, some v infinity.
And then when the input
goes away, the neuron--
the firing rate decays
exponentially towards zero.
OK, so in the case where
lambda is equal to one,
you can see that this
coefficient is zero.
And now you can see
that the derivative
of the firing rate of the neuron
is just equal to the input.
What that means is that the
firing rate of the neuron
essentially
integrates the input.
And you can see, if you put
a step input into this neuron
with this recurrent connection
of lambda equal one,
that the response of the neuron
simply ramps up linearly,
which corresponds to
integrating that step input.
And then when the
input is turned off
and goes back to
zero, you can see
that the firing rate of
the neuron stays constant.
And that's because
the leak is exactly
balanced by this excitatory
recurrent input from the neuron
onto itself.
So you can see that for the
case for lambda equals one,
there's persistent
activity after you
put an input into this neuron.
And we talked about how this
forms a short-term memory that
can be used for a bunch
of different things.
It's a short-term
memory of a scalar,
or a continuous quantity,
like I position.
Or we talked about short-term
memory integration being used
for path integration or for
accumulating evidence across
noisy--
over long exposure
to a noisy stimulus.
So today, we're going to focus
on networks where this lambda
is greater than one.
And in that case, you can see
that the differential equation
looks like this.
So if lambda is
greater than one,
then the quantity inside the
parentheses here is negative.
But that's multiplied
by a minus one.
So the coefficient in
front of the v is positive.
So if v itself is
a positive number,
then dv dt is also positive.
So if v is positive
and dv dt is positive,
then what that means is that
the firing rate of that neuron
is growing and, in this case,
is growing exponentially.
So that when you put an input
in, the response of the neuron
grows exponentially.
But when you turn the input off,
the firing rate of the neuron
continues to grow exponentially,
which is a little bit crazy.
You know that neurons
in the brain, of course,
don't have firing
rates that just
keep growing exponentially.
So we're going to solve that
problem by using nonlinearities
in the firing F-I
curve of neurons.
But the key point here is
that this kind of network
actually remembers that there
was an input, as opposed
to this kind of network, where
the when the input goes away,
the activity of the network
just decays back to zero.
This kind of network
has no memory
that there was an input
long ago in the past.
Whereas, this kind
of network remembers
that there was an input.
And so that kind of property
when lambda is greater than one
is useful for storing memories.
So we're going to
expand on that idea.
In particular, we're
going to use that theme
to build networks that
have attractors, that
have stable states
that they can go to,
that depend on prior
inputs, but also can be used
to store long-term memories.
All right?
We're going to see how
that kind of network
can also be used to produce a
winner-take-all network that
is sensitive to
which of two inputs
are stronger and stores a
memory of preceding inputs
where one input is
stronger than the other.
Or it ends up in a different
state when, let's say, input
one is stronger
than input 2, and it
lands in a different
state when input 2 is
stronger than input one.
We're going to then describe
a particular model, called
a Hopfield model, for how
attractor networks can
store long-term memories.
We're going to introduce
the idea of an energy
landscape, which is a
property of networks that
have symmetric connections,
of which the Hopfield model is
an example.
And then we're going
to end by talking
about how many memories such
a network can actually store,
known as the capacity problem.
OK, so let's start
with recurrent networks
with lambda greater than one.
So let's start with our autapse.
Let's put lambda equal to 2.
And again, you can see that
if we rewrite this equation
with lambda greater
than one, we can
write tau dv dt equals lambda
minus one times v plus h.
You can see that
the value of zero,
at the firing rate of
zero, is an unstable fixed
point of the network.
Why is that?
Because at v equals zero,
then dv dt equals zero.
So what that means is that
if the firing rate is exactly
zero, that's a fixed
point of the system.
But if v deviates very
slightly from zero,
v becomes very
slightly positive,
then dv dt is positive, and
the firing rate of the neuron
starts running away.
So what you can see is if you
start the fire rate at zero
and have the input at
zero, then dv dt is zero,
and the network will
stay at zero firing rate.
But if you put in a very
slight, a very small input, then
dv dt goes positive, and the
network activity runs away.
Now, let's put in an input
of the opposite sign.
So now let's start
with v equals zero
and put in a very
tiny negative input.
What's the network going to do?
So tau dv dt equals v. So v
is very slightly negative,
or if h is very slightly
negative and v is zero,
then dv dt will be negative,
and the network will run away
in the negative direction.
So this network actually
can produce two memories.
It can produce a memory that a
preceding input was positive,
or it can store a memory that
a preceding input was negative.
So it has two
configurations after you've
put in an input that is
positive or negative, right?
It can produce a positive output
or a negative output that's
persistent for a long time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the [INAUDIBLE]
of a negative firing
rate [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So you can basically
reformulate everything
that we've been talking
about for neurons
that have zero, that can't
have negative firing rates.
But in this case, we've been
working with linear neurons.
And it seems like the
negative fire rates are pretty
non-physical, non-intuitive.
But it's a pretty standard way
to do the mathematical analysis
for neurons like this, is
to treat them as linear.
But you can sort of reformulate
all of these networks
in a way that don't have
that non-physical property.
So for now, let's just bear
with this slightly uncomfortable
situation of having neurons
that have negative firing rates.
Generally, we're going to
associate negative firing rates
as inhibition, OK?
But don't worry about that here.
All right, so we're going
to solve this problem
that these neurons have firing
rates that are kind of running
away exponentially by adding a
nonlinear activation function.
So a typical
nonlinear activation
function that you might
use for linear neurons,
like for networks of the
type we've been considering,
is a symmetric F-I curve,
where if the input is
positive and small, the
firing rate of the neuron
grows linearly, until you reach
a point where it saturates.
And larger inputs don't
produce any larger firing
rate of the neuron.
So most neurons actually have
kind of a saturating F-I curve,
like this, like the
Hodgkin-Huxley neurons begin
to saturate.
Why is that?
Because the sodium channels
begin to inactivate,
and it can't fire
any faster than the--
there's a time
between spikes that's
sort of the closest that
the neuron-- the fastest
that the neuron can
spike because of sodium
channel inactivation.
And then on the minus
side, if the input
is small and negative, then
the firing rate of the neuron
goes negative
linearly for a while
and then saturates
at some value.
And we typically have the
neuron saturating between one
and minus one.
So now, if you start your
neuron at zero firing rate
and you put in a
little positive input,
what's the neuron going to do?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
It's going to start
running up exponentially,
but then it's going
to saturate up here.
And so the firing rate
will run up and sit at one.
And if we put in a negative
input, a small negative input,
then the neuron--
then this little
recurrent network
will go negative and
saturate at minus one, OK?
So you can see that
this network actually
has one unstable fixed point,
where if it sits exactly
at zero, it will stay
at zero, until you
give a little bit of
input in either direction.
And then the network will run up
and sit at another fixed point
here of one.
If you put in a
big negative input,
you can drive it to
another fixed point.
And these two are
stable fixed points,
because once they're
in that state,
if you give little
perturbations to the network,
it will deviate a little
bit from that value.
If you give a small
negative input,
you can cause this to
decrease a little bit.
But then when the input goes
away, it will relax back.
So this is an
unstable fixed point,
and these are two
stable fixed points.
Now, we're going to come back
to this in more detail later.
But we often think
about networks
like this as sort of
like a ball on a hill.
So you can imagine that you
can describe this network using
what's called an
energy landscape, where
if you start this system
at some point on this sort
of valley-shaped
hill, all right,
the network sort of-- it's like
a ball that rolls downhill.
So if you start the network
exactly at the peak,
the ball will sit there.
But if you give it a
little bit of a nudge,
it will roll downhill toward
one of these stable points, OK?
If you start it slightly
on the other side,
it will roll this way, OK?
And those stable fixed
points are called attractors.
And this particular
network has two tractors--
one with a firing
rate of one and one
at a firing rate of minus one.
Yes, Appolonia?
AUDIENCE: The
stable fixed points
of the top graph, where'd
you say they were?
MICHALE FEE: The
stable fixed point
is here, because once you--
if the system is
in this state, you
can give slight
perturbations and the system
returns to that fixed point.
This is an unstable fixed
point, because if you
start the system
there and give it
a little nudge in either
direction, the state runs away.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHALE FEE: Any
questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How is the shape of
the curve [INAUDIBLE] points
determined based on like--
MICHALE FEE: So
I'm going to get--
I'm going to come back
to how you actually
calculate this energy
landscape more formally.
There's a very precise
mathematical definition
of how you define
this energy landscape.
All right, so this was all
for the case of one neuron,
all right?
So now let's extend it to
the case of multiple neurons.
So let's just take two
neurons with an autapse.
One of these autapses have
a value strength of two,
and the other autapse have
a strength of minus two.
So this one is recurrent
and excitatory.
This one is recurrent
and inhibitory.
So now what we're
going to do is we can
plot the state of the network.
Now, instead of being
the state of the network
in one dimension, v, we're
now going to have v1 and v2.
So the state of
the system is going
to be a point in a plane
given by v1 and v2.
So now, by looking
at this network,
you can see immediately
that this particular neuron,
this neuron with a
firing rate of v2,
looks like the kind of
network that we've already
studied, right?
It has a stable
fixed point at zero.
And this network has two
stable fixed points--
one at one and the
other one at minus one.
So you can see that
this system will also
have two stable fixed points--
one there and one there, right?
Because if I take
the input away,
this neuron is either
going to one or minus one,
and this neuron is
going to go to zero.
So there's one and minus
one on the v1 axis.
And those two states have zero
firing rate on the v2 axis.
Is that clear?
So now what's going to happen
if we made this autapse have
a strength of two?
Anybody want to take a guess?
AUDIENCE: That's,
like, four attractors?
MICHALE FEE: Right.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because that will
also have stable fixed points
at [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Right.
So this one will have
stable fixed points
at one and minus one.
This will also have
stable fixed points at one
and minus one, right?
And the system can be in
any one of four states--
0, 0.
Sorry, 1, 1; minus 1, minus
1; 1 minus 1; and minus 1, 1.
That's right.
All right, so I just want to
make one other point here,
which is that no
matter where you start
the system for
this network, it's
going to evolve towards one
of these stable fixed points,
unless I started it exactly
right there at zero.
That will be
another fixed point,
but that's an
unstable fixed point.
OK, so this system will--
no matter where
I start the state
of that system, other than
that exact point right there,
the network will evolve toward
one of those two attractors.
That's why they're
called attractors,
because they attract the
state of the system toward one
of those two points.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are the attractors
determined by the nonlinear
activation function?
MICHALE FEE: They are.
So if this non-linear activation
function saturated at two
and minus two, then these two
points would be up here at two
and minus two.
So you could see that this
network has two eigenvalues,
right?
If we think of it
as a linear network,
this network has
two eigenvalues.
The connection matrix is given
by a diagonal matrix with a two
and a minus two along
the diagonals, right?
So let's take a look at
this kind of network.
Now, instead of an
autapse network,
we have recurrent connections
of strength minus 2 and minus 2.
So what does that
weight matrix look like?
AUDIENCE: 0, minus
2; minus 2, 0.
MICHALE FEE: 0, minus
2; minus 2, 0, right?
Well, what are the
eigenvalues of this network?
Anybody remember that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Right.
It's a plus b and a minus b.
And so the eigenvalues
of this network
are 0 plus negative 2
and 0 minus negative 2.
So it's 2 and minus 2, right?
So this network here will have
exactly the same eigenvalues
as this network.
But what's going
to be different?
What are the eigenvectors?
AUDIENCE: The 45.
MICHALE FEE: The 45 degrees.
So the eigenvectors of this
network are the x- and y-axes.
The eigenvectors of this
network are the 45-degree lines.
So anybody want to
take a guess as to what
the stable states of this--
it's just this network
rotated by 45 degrees, right?
So those are now the attractors
of this network, right?
And that makes sense, right?
This neuron can be
positive, but that's
going to be strongly driving
this neuron negative.
But if this neuron
is negative, that's
going to be strongly driving
this neuron positive, right?
And so this network will
want to sit out here
on this line in this direction
or in this direction.
And because of the saturation--
if there were no saturation,
if this were a linear network,
the activity of this
neuron would just
be running exponentially
up these 45-degree lines.
But because of
the saturation, it
gets stuck here at 1, minus 1.
Or rather, minus
1, 1 or 1, minus 1.
Any questions about that?
Yeah, Jasmine?
AUDIENCE: So the two
fixed points right now,
like it's [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
It'll be one in this direction
and one in that direction.
AUDIENCE: So why [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Because
this neuron is saturated.
Because the saturation is acting
at the level of the individual
neurons.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHALE FEE: So each
neuron will go up
to its own saturation point.
OK?
All right.
So this kind of network
is actually pretty cool.
This network can
implement decision-making.
It can decide, for example,
whether one input is bigger
than the other, all right?
So if we have an input--
so let's start our
network right here
at this unstable fixed
point, all right?
We've carefully balanced
the ball on top of the hill,
and it just sits there.
And now let's put an input
that is in this direction h,
so that it's slightly
pointing to the right
of this diagonal line.
So what's going to happen?
It's going to kick the
state of the network
up in this direction, right?
But we've already discussed
how if the network state is
anywhere on either
side of that line,
it will evolve toward
the fixed point.
If the h is on
the other side, it
will kick the network
unstable fixed point
into this part of
the state space.
And then the network will evolve
toward this fixed point, OK?
These half planes
here, this region here,
is called the attractor
basin for this attractor.
And on this side, it's
called attractor basin
for that attractor, OK?
And you can see that
this network will
be very sensitive to
whichever input, h1 or h2,
is slightly larger.
So let me show you
what that looks
like in this little movie.
So we're going to
start with our network
exactly at the zero point.
And we're going to give an
input in this direction.
And you can see that we've
kicked the network slightly
this way.
And now the network evolves
toward the fixed point,
and it stays there.
Now if we give a
big input this way,
we can push network
over, push it
to the other side of this
dividing line between the two
basins of attraction,
and now the network
sits here at this fixed point.
We can kick it again with
another input and push it back.
So it's kind of like
a flip-flop, right?
It's pretty cool.
It detects which
input was larger,
pushes the network into an
attractor that then remembers
which input was
larger for, basically,
as long as the network--
as long as you allow the
network to sit there.
OK?
All right, any
questions about that?
Yes, Rebecca?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So the basin is just like
each side of that [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: That's right.
That's the basin of
attraction for this attractor.
If you start the network
anywhere in this half plane,
the network will evolve
toward that attractor.
And you can use that as a
winner-take-all decision-making
network by starting the
network right there at zero.
And small kicks in
either direction
will cause the network to relax
into one of these attractors
and maintain that memory.
Now let's talk about sort
of a formal implementation
of a system for producing
memories, long-term memories,
all right?
And that's called
a Hopfield model.
And the Hopfield
model is actually
one of the best current
models for understanding
how memory systems like
the hippocampus work.
So the basic idea
is that we have
neurons in the hippocampus, in
particular in the CA3 region
of the hippocampus, that
have very prominent-- a lot
of recurrent connectivity
between those neurons,
all right?
And so you have input
from entorhinal cortex
and from the dentate
gyrus that sort of serve
as the stimuli that come
into that network and form--
and burn memories into
that part of the network
by changing the synaptic
weights within that network.
[INAUDIBLE] that
some time later,
when similar inputs
come in, they
can reactivate the memory
in the hippocampus.
And you recognize and remember
that pattern of stimuli.
All right, so we're going to--
actually, so an example of
how this looks when you record
neurons in the hippocampus,
it looks like this.
So here's a mouse or a rat with
electrodes in its hippocampus.
If you put it in a
little arena like this,
it will run around and
explore for a while.
You can record where the rat
is in that arena [AUDIO OUT]
from neurons.
And measure when the
neurons spike and look
at how the firing
rate of those neurons
relates to the
position of the animal.
So the black trace here shows
all of the locations where
the rat was when it was
running around the maze,
and the red dot shows where
one of these neurons in CA3
of the hippocampus generated a
spike, where the rat was when
that neuron generates a spike.
And those are shown
with red dots here.
And you can see that
this neuron generates
spiking when the animal is in
a particular restricted region
of the cage, of its environment.
And different neurons show
different localized regions.
So these regions are
called place fields,
because they are the places
in the environment where
that neurons spikes.
Different neurons have
different place fields.
You can actually record
from many of these neurons--
and looking at the pattern
of neurons that are spiking,
you can actually figure
out where the rat was or is
at any given moment,
just by looking at which
of these neurons is spiking.
That's pretty obvious, right?
If this neuron is spiking
and this neuron isn't, all
these other neurons,
then the animal
is going to be-- you know
that the animal is somewhere
in that location right there.
All right, so in a sense,
the activity of these neurons
reflects the animal remembering,
or sort of remembering,
that it's in a
particular location.
It's in a cage.
It looks at the walls
of the environment.
It sees a little--
they use colored
cards on the wall
to give the animal
cues as to where it is.
So they look around and they
say, oh, yeah, I'm here.
In my environment, there's a
red card there and a yellow card
there, and that's
where I am right now.
So that's the way you think
about these hippocampal place
fields as being like a memory.
On top of that, this
part of the hippocampus
is necessary for the actual
formation of memories
in a broader sense-- not
just spatial locations,
but more generally in terms
of life events, right?
For humans, the hippocampus
is an essential part
of the brain for
storing memories.
All right, so let's
come back to this idea
of our recurrent network.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to start adding
more and more neurons
to our recurrent network.
All right, so here's
what the attractor
looked like for
the case where we
have one eigenvalue in the
system that's greater than one,
another one that's
less than one.
If we now make both
of these neurons
have recurrent connections
that are stronger than one,
now we're going to have
four attractors, right?
Each one of these has
two stable fixed points--
a one and minus one.
So here, for these
two states, v1 is one.
And for these two
states, v1 is negative 1.
For these two states, v2
is 1, and these two states,
v2 is negative one, all right?
So you can see every time
we add another neuron
or another neuron to our
network that has an autapse,
every time we add another
neuron with another eigenvalue,
we add more possible
states of the network, OK?
So if we had two neurons,
we have one neuron
with an eigenvalue with an
autapse greater than one,
we have two states.
If we have two, we
have four states.
If we have three of those,
we have eight states.
So you can see that if we
have n of these neurons
with recurrent excitation with
a lambda of greater than one,
we have 2 to the
n possible states
that that system can be in, OK?
So I don't know exactly how
many neurons are in CA3.
It has to be several
million, maybe 10 million.
We don't know the exact number.
But 2 to that is a lot of
possible states, right?
So the problem is that--
so let's think about how
this thing acts as a memory.
So it turns out that this little
device that we've built here
is actually a lot like
a computer memory.
It's like a register,
where we can write a value.
So we can write in
here a 1, minus 1, 1.
And as long as we leave
that network alone,
it will store that value.
Or we can write a 1, 1, 1,
and it will store that value.
But that's not really
what we mean when
we talk about memories, right?
We have a memory of meeting
somebody for lunch yesterday,
right?
That is a particular
configuration of sensory inputs
that we experienced.
So the other way to think about
this is this kind of network
is just a short-term memory.
We can program in some values--
1, 1, 1.
But if we were to turn the
activity of these neurons off,
we'd erase the memory, right?
How do we build
into this network
a long-term memory,
something that we
can turn all these
neurons off and then
the network sort of goes back
into the remembered state?
You do that by
building connections
between these neurons,
such that only some
of these possible
states are actually
stable states, all right?
So let me give you
an example of this.
So if you have a whole
bunch of neurons--
n neurons.
You've got 2 to the
n possible states
that that network can sit in.
What we want is for
only some of those
to actually be stable
states of the system.
So, for example, when we
wake up in the morning
and we see the dresser or maybe
the nightstand next to the bed,
we want to remember
that's our bedroom.
We want that to be a particular
configuration of inputs
that we recall, right?
So what you want is you
want a set of neurons
that have particular states
that the system evolves
toward that are stable
states of the system.
So the way you do
that is you take
this network with
recurrent autapses
and you build cross-connections
between them that
make particular of
those possible states
actual stable states
of the system.
We want to restrict the number
of stable states in the system.
So take a look at
this network here.
So here we have two neurons.
You know that if you had
autapses between these--
of these neurons to
themselves, there
would be four possible
stable states.
But if we now build
excitatory cross-connections
between those neurons,
two of those states
actually are no
longer stable states.
They become unstable.
And only these two remain
stable states of this system,
remain attractors.
If we put inhibitory connections
between those neurons,
then we can make these
two states the attractors
of the system, OK?
All right.
Does that make sense?
All right, so let's
actually flesh out
the mathematics of how you
take a network of neurons
and program it to
have particular states
that are tractors of
the system, all right?
So we've been using this
kind of dynamical equation.
We're going to simplify that.
We're going to follow
the construction
that John Hopfield
used when he analyzed
these recurrent networks.
And instead of writing
down a continuous update so
that we update the-- in the
formulation we've been using,
we update the firing
rate of our neuron
using this
differential equation.
We're going to simplify
it by just writing down
the state of the network
at time t plus 1.
That's a function of
the state of the network
of the previous time step.
So we're going to
discretize time.
We're going to say v,
the state of the network,
the firing rates of all the
neurons at time t plus 1,
is just a function
of a weight matrix
that connects all the neurons
times the state of the system,
times the firing rate vector.
And then this can also have
an input into it, all right?
All right.
And here, I'm just writing
out exactly what that matrix
multiplication looks like.
It's the state of the i-th
[vector?] after we update
the state of the network is just
a sum over all of the different
inputs coming from all
of the other neurons,
all the j other neurons.
And we're going to simplify
our neuronal activation
function to just make it into
a binary threshold neuron.
So if the input is positive,
then the firing rate of neuron
will be positive.
If the input is negative,
the firing rate of the neuron
will be negative.
All right?
And that's the sine function.
It's 1 if x is greater
than 0 and minus 1
if x is less than or equal to 0.
All right, so the goal is
to build a network that
can store any memory we
want, any pattern we want,
and turn that into
a stable state.
So we're going to
build a network that
will evolve toward a particular
pattern that we want.
And xi is just a pattern
of ones and minus ones
that describes that
memory that we're building
into the network, all right?
So xi is just a one or
minus one for every neuron
in the network.
So xi i is one or minus
one for the i-th neuron.
Now, we want xi to be
an attractor, right?
We want to build a network
such that xi is an attractor.
And what that means is that--
what does building
a network mean?
When we say build a network,
what are we actually doing?
What is it here that we're
actually trying to decide?
AUDIENCE: The seminal roots.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, which is?
AUDIENCE: Like the matrix M.
MICHALE FEE: The M, right.
So when I say build a
network that does this,
I mean choose a set of M's
that has this property.
So what we want is we want
to find a weight matrix M
such that if the network
is in a stable state,
is in this desired
state, that when
we multiply that state
times the matrix M
and we take the
sine of that sum,
you're going to get
the same state back.
In other words, you start
the network in this state,
it's going to end up
in the same state.
That's what it means to
have an attractor, OK?
That's what it means to say
that it's a stable state.
OK, so we're going to
try a particular matrix.
And I'm going to describe
what this actually
looks like in more detail.
But the matrix that
programs a pattern
xi into the network
as an attractor
is this weight
matrix right here.
So if we have a pattern
xi, our weight matrix
is some constant times
the outer product
of that pattern with itself.
I'm going to explain
what that means.
What that means is that
if neuron i and neuron
j are both active
in this pattern,
both have a firing
rate of one, then
those two neurons are going
to be connected to each other,
right?
They're going to have a
connection between them that
has a value of one, or alpha.
If one of those neurons
has a firing rate of one
and the other neuron has
a firing rate of zero,
then what weight do
we want between them?
If one of them has
a firing rate of one
and the other has a
firing rate of minus one,
the strength of the connection
we want between them
is minus one.
So if one neuron is active
and another neuron is active,
we want them to excite
each other to maintain
that as a stable state.
If one neuron is plus and
the other one is minus,
we want them to
inhibit each other,
because that will make
that configuration stable.
OK, notice that's
a symmetric matrix.
So let's actually take our
dynamical equation that
says how we go from
the state at time t
to the state of time t plus 1
and put in this weight matrix
and see whether this pattern
xi is actually a stable state.
So let's do that,
Let's take this M and stick
it in there, substitute it in.
Notice this is a sum over j,
so we can pull the xi i out.
And now, you see that
v at t plus 1 is this.
And it's the sine of
a times xi i times
the sum of j of xi j, xi k.
Now, what is that?
Any idea what that is?
So the elements of xi are what?
They're just ones or minus ones.
So xi j times xi j has to be?
AUDIENCE: One.
MICHALE FEE: One.
And we're summing
over n neurons.
So this sum has to
have a value N. So
you can see that the
state at time t plus 1--
if we start to network
in this stored state,
it's just this-- sine of a N xi.
But a is positive.
N is just a positive
integer, number of neurons.
So this equal xi.
So if we have this
weight matrix,
we start to network
in that stored state,
the state at the next time
step will be the same state.
So it's a stable fixed point.
All right, so let's just
go through an example.
That is the prescription
for programming a memory
into a Hopfield network, OK?
And notice that it's just--
it's essentially a
Hebbian learning rule.
So the way you do this is
you activate the neurons
with a particular pattern, and
any two neurons that are active
together form a positive
excitatory connection
between them.
Any two neurons
where one is positive
and the other is negative
form a symmetric inhibitory
connection, all right?
All right, so let's take
a particular example.
Let's make a
three-neuron network that
stores a pattern 1, 1, minus 1.
And again, the notation
here is xi, xi transpose.
That's an outer
product, just like you
use to compute the covariance
matrix of a data matrix.
So there's a pattern
we're going to program in.
The weight matrix
is xi, xi transpose,
but it's 1, 1, minus
1 times 1, 1, minus 1.
You can see that's going
to give you this matrix
here, all right?
So that element
there is 1 times 1.
That element there.
So here are two neurons.
These two neurons storing this
pattern, these two neurons--
sorry, this neuron has a
firing rate of minus one.
So the connection between
that neuron and itself
is a one, right?
It's just the product
of that times that.
All right any questions about
how we got this weight matrix?
I think it's pretty
straightforward.
So is that a stable point?
Let's just multiply it out.
We take this vector and
multiply it by this matrix.
There's our stored pattern.
There's our matrix that
stores that pattern.
And we're just going
to multiply this out.
You can see that 1
times 1 plus 1 times 1
plus minus 1 times minus 1 is 3.
You just do that for
each of the neurons.
Take the sine of that.
And you can see that
that's just 1, 1, minus 1.
So 1, 1, minus 1 is
a stable fixed point.
Now let's see if it's
actually an attractor.
So when a state is an
attractor, what that means is
if we start to network
at a state that's
a little bit different from
that and advance the network one
time step, it will converge
toward the attractor.
So into our network that stores
this pattern 1, 1, minus 1,
let's put in a different
pattern and see what happens.
So we're going to take
that weight matrix,
multiply it by this initial
state, multiply it out,
and you can see
that next state is
going to be the sine
of 3, 3, minus 3.
And one time step advanced,
the network is now in the state
that we've programmed in.
Does that make sense?
So that state is a stable fixed
point and it's an attractor.
I'm just going to go
through this very quickly.
I'm just going to prove that xi
is an attractor of the network
if we write down the network
as the outer product of this.
The matrix elements
are the outer product
of the stored state, OK?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to calculate the total
input onto the i-th neuron
if we start from an
arbitrary state, v. So k
is the input to all
the neurons, right?
And it's just that matrix
times the initial state.
So v j is the firing
rate of the j-th neuron,
and k is just M times v.
That's the pattern of inputs
to all of our neurons.
So what is that? k equals--
we're just going to
put this weight matrix
into this equation, all right?
We can pull the xi i
outside of the sum,
because it doesn't depend on j.
The sum is over j.
Now let's just write
out this sum, OK?
Now, you can see
that if you start out
with an initial state that has
some number of neurons that
have the correct sign that
are already overlapping
with the memorized state
and some number of neurons
in that initial
state don't overlap
with the memorized
state, we can write out
this sum as two terms.
We can write it as a sum
over some of the neurons that
are already in the correct state
and a sum over neurons that
are not in the correct state.
So if these neurons
in that initial state
have the right sign, that means
these two have the same sign.
And so the sum over
xi j vj for neurons
where v has the
right sign is just
the number of neurons
that has the correct sign.
And this sum over
incorrect neurons
means these neurons have the
opposite sign of the desired
memory.
And so those will be one,
and those will be minus one.
Or those will be minus
one, and those will be one.
And so this will be minus the
number of incorrect neurons.
So you can see that
the input of the neuron
will have the right sign if
the number of correct neurons
is more than the number of
incorrect neurons, all right?
So what that means is that
if you program a pattern
into this network
and then I drive
an input into the network,
where most of the inputs drive--
if the input drives most of the
neurons with the right sign,
then the inputs will
cause the network
to evolve toward the memorized
pattern in the next timestamp.
OK, so let me say that again,
because I felt like that
didn't come out very clearly.
We program a pattern
into our network.
If we start to network at some--
let's say at zero.
And then we put in a pattern
into the network such
that just the majority
of the neurons
are activated in a way that
looks like the stored pattern,
then in the next time
step, all of the neurons
will have this stored pattern.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
Let me actually go
ahead and show you--
OK, so here's an
example of that.
So you can use Hopfield
networks to store
many different kinds of things,
including images, all right?
So this is a network
where each pixel
is being represented by a
neuron in a Hopfield network.
And a particular image
was stored in that network
by setting up the pattern
of synaptic weights
just using that xi, xi transpose
learning rule for the weight
matrix M, OK?
Now, what you can do is you
can [INAUDIBLE] that network
from a random initial condition.
And then let the network
evolve over time, all right?
And what you see is that
the network converges
toward the pattern that was
stored in the synaptic [?], OK?
Does that make sense?
Got that?
So, basically, as long
as that initial pattern
has some overlap with
the stored pattern,
the network will evolve
toward the stored pattern.
All right, so let me
define a little bit
better what we mean by
the energy landscape
and how it's actually defined.
OK, so you remember that
if we start our network
in a particular pattern v,
the recurrent connections
will drive inputs into all
the neurons in the network.
And those inputs
will then determine
the pattern of activity
at the next time step.
So if we have a state
of the network v,
the inputs to the network, to
all the neurons in the network,
from the currently
active neurons
is given by the
connection matrix times v.
So we can just write that
out as a sum like this.
So you define the energy of the
network as the dot product--
basically, the
amount of overlap--
between the current
state of the network
and the inputs to
all of the neurons
that drive the activity
in the next step, OK?
And the energy is minus, OK?
So what that means is if the
network is in a state that
has a big overlap with the
pattern of inputs to all
the other neurons,
then the energy will
be very negative, right?
And remember, the system likes
to evolve toward low energies.
In physics, you have
a ball on a hill.
It rolls downhill, right, to
lower gravitational energies.
So you start the ball
anywhere on the hill,
and it will roll downhill.
So these networks
do the same thing.
They evolve downward
on this energy surface.
They evolve towards
states that have
a high overlap with the inputs
that drive the next state.
Does that make sense?
So if you're in a state
where the pattern right now
has a high overlap with
what the pattern is going
to be in the next time step,
then you're in an attractor,
right?
OK, so it looks like that.
So this energy is just
negative of the overlap
of the current state of the
network with the pattern
of inputs to all the neurons.
Yes, Rebecca?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] to
say [INAUDIBLE] with the weight
matrix, since that's sort of
the goal of the next time step,
and it will evolve towards
the matrix [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So the only difference is
that the state of the network
is this vector, right?
And the weight matrix tells us
how that state will drive input
into all the other neurons.
And so if you're in a state
that drives a pattern of inputs
to all the neurons that looks
exactly like the current state,
then you're going to stay
in that state, right?
And so the energy is just
defined as that dot product,
the overlap of the current
state, or the state
that you're calculating
the energy of,
and the inputs to the network
in the next time step.
All right, so let me show
you what that looks like.
And so the energy is
lowest, current state
has a high overlap
with the synaptic drive
to the next step.
So let's just take a look at
this particular network here.
I've rewritten this
dot product as--
so k is just M times
v. This dot product
can just be written as
v transpose times Mv.
So that's the energy.
Let's take a look at this
matrix, this network here--
0, minus 2, minus 2, 0.
So it's this mutually
inhibitory network.
You know that that
inhibitory network
has attractors that are here
at minus 1, 1 and 1, minus 1.
So let's actually
calculate the energy.
So you can actually
take these states--
1, minus 1-- multiply
it by that M,
and then take the dot
product with 1, minus 1.
And do that for each
one of those states
and write down the energy.
You can see that the
energy here is minus 1.
The energy here is minus 1,
and the energy here is 0.
So if you start the network
here, at an energy zero,
it's going to roll
downhill to this state.
Or it can roll
downhill to this state,
depending on the
initial condition, OK?
So you can also think about the
energy as a function of firing
rates continuously.
You can calculate that energy,
not just for these points
on this grid.
And what you see is
that there's basically--
in high dimensions,
there are sort
of valleys that
describe the attractor
basin of these different
attractors, all right?
And if you project that energy
along an axis like this,
you can see that you sort of--
let's say, take a slice
through this energy function.
You can see that this
looks just like the energy
surface, the energy function,
that we described before
for the 1D factor, the single
neuron with two attractors,
right?
This corresponds to
a valley and a valley
and a peak between them.
And then the energy gets
big outside of that.
And questions about that?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] vector 1/2
because-- in this case, right?
MICHALE FEE: That's the general
definition, minus 1/2 v dot k.
It actually doesn't really--
this 1/2 doesn't really matter.
It actually comes out of
the derivative of something,
as I recall.
But a scaling factor
doesn't matter.
The network always evolves
toward a minimum of the energy.
And so this 1/2
could be anything.
All right, so the point is that
starting the network anywhere
with a sensory input, the system
will evolve toward the nearest
memory, OK?
And I already showed you this.
OK, so now, a very
interesting question
is, how many memories can you
actually store in a network?
And there's a very simple way
of calculating the capacity
of the Hopfield network.
And I'm just going to show
you the outlines of it.
And that actually
gives us some insight
into what kinds of
memories you can store.
Basically, the idea is that
when you store memories
in a network, you want
the different memories
to be as uncorrelated with
each other as possible.
You don't want to try
to store memories that
are very similar to each other.
And you'll see why in a second
when we look at the map.
So let's say that we want
to store multiple memories
in our network.
So instead of just
storing one pattern, xi,
we want to store a bunch
of different patterns xi.
And so let's say we're going
to store P different patterns.
So we have a
parameter variable mu.
An index mu addresses each
of the different patterns
we want to store.
So we're going to store zero to
p patterns, p minus 1 patterns.
So what we do, the
way we do that is
we compute the
contribution to the weight
make matrix from each of
those different patterns.
So we calculate a weight
matrix using the outer product
for each of the patterns we
want to store in the network,
all right?
And then we add all
of those together.
We're going to essentially sort
of average together the network
that we would make for
each pattern separately.
Does that makes sense?
So there is the equation
for the weight matrix
that stores p different patterns
in our memory, in our network.
And that's how we got
this kind of network
here, where we store
multiple memories, all right?
So let me just show
you an example of what
happens when you do that.
So I found these
nice videos online.
So here is a representation
of a network that stores
a five by five array of pixels.
And this network was trained on
these three different patterns.
And what this
little demo shows is
that if you start the network
from different configurations
here and then evolve the
network-- you start running it.
That means you run the
dynamic update for each neuron
one at a time, and
you can see how
this system evolves over time.
So this is a little
GUI-based thing.
You can flip the
state and then run it.
And you can see that if
you change those, now it--
I think he was trying to
make it look like that.
But when you run it, it actually
evolved toward this one.
He's going to really
make it look like that.
And you can see it
evolves toward that one.
All right, any
questions about that?
You can see it stored
three separate memories.
You've given an
input, and the network
evolves toward whatever memory
was closest to the input.
So that's called a content
[INAUDIBLE] memory.
You can actually
recall a memory--
not by pointing to an address,
like you do in a computer,
but by putting in
something that looks
a little bit like the memory.
And then the system
evolves right to the memory
that was closest to the input.
So it's also called an
auto-associative memory.
It automatically associates
with the nearest--
with a pattern that's
nearest to the input.
So here's another example.
It's just kind of
more of the same.
This is a network
similar to this.
Instead of black and
white, it's red and purple,
but it's got a lot more pixels.
And you'll see the
three different images
that are stored in there--
so a face, a world,
and a penguin.
So then what they're doing
here is they add noise.
And then you run the
network, and it [AUDIO OUT]
one of the patterns
that you stored in it.
So here's the penguin.
Add noise.
Add a little bit of noise.
Here, he's coloring it
in, I guess, to make it.
And then you run
the network, and it
remembers the [AUDIO OUT].
OK, so that's interesting.
So he ran it.
He or she ran the network.
And you see that it kind
of recovered a face,
but there's some penguin
head stuck on top.
So what goes wrong there?
Something bad happened, right?
The network was trained with a
face, a globe, and a penguin.
And you run it most of
the time, and it works.
And then, suddenly, you run
it, and it recovers a face
with a penguin head
sticking out of it.
What happened?
So we'll explain what happens.
What happened was
that that this network
was trained in a
way that has what's
called a spurious attractor.
And that often happens
when you train a network
with too many memories,
when you exceed
the capacity of the
network to store memories.
So let me show you what actually
goes wrong mathematically
there.
All right, so we're going
to do the same analysis
we did before.
We're going to take a matrix.
We're going to build a network
that stores multiple memories.
This was the matrix
to build one memory.
Let's see what I did here.
So in order for--
Yeah.
Sorry.
This was the matrix
for multiple memories.
We're summing mu.
I just didn't write
the mu equals 0 to p.
So we're going to program
p different memories
by summing up this outer product
for all the different patterns
that we're wanting
to store, all right?
We're going to ask
whether one of those--
under what conditions is one
of those patterns, the xi 0,
actually a stable
state of the network?
So we're going to
build a network
with multiple patterns
stored, and we're just
going to ask a simple question.
Under what conditions is xi
0 going to evolve to xi 0?
And if xi 0 evolves toward
xi 0, or stays at xi 0,
then it's a stable point.
All right, so let's do that.
We're going to take
that weight matrix,
and we're going to plug-in
our multiple memory weight
matrix, all right?
You can see that we
can pull out the xi
i out of this sum over j.
And the next step is we're
going to separate this
into a sum over mu equals
zero and a separate sum for mu
not equal to 0, all right?
So this is a sum
over all the mu's,
but we're going to
pull out the mu zero
term as a separate sum over j.
Is that clear?
Anyway, this is just for fun.
You don't have to reproduce
this, so don't worry.
So we're going to pull out
the mu equals zero term.
And what does that look like?
It's xi i0, sum over
j of xi j0, xi j0.
So what is that?
That's just N, right,
the number of neurons.
We're summing over j equals
1 to N, number of neurons.
I should add those limits here.
So you can see that that's N.
So this is just sine of xi i0
plus a bunch of other stuff.
So you can see right away that
if all of this other stuff
is really small, then
this is a fixed point.
Because if all this
stuff is small,
the system will evolve toward
the sine of xi [INAUDIBLE],,
which is just xi i0.
So let's take a look
at all of this stuff
and see what can go wrong
to make this not small.
All right, so let's zoom in
on this particular term right
here.
So what is this?
This is sum over
j, xi mu j, xi 0 j.
So what is that?
Anybody know what that is?
It's a vector operation.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: The dot
product between one image
and then zero.
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
It's a dot product between
the image that we're asking
is it a stable fixed point
and all the other images
in the network.
Sorry, and the mu-th image.
So what this is saying
is that if our image is
orthogonal to all the
other images in the network
that we've tried to store,
then this thing is zero.
So this is referred
to as crosstalk
between the stored memories.
So if our pattern, xi
0, is orthogonal to all
the other patterns, then
it will be a fixed point.
So the capacity of the
network, the crosstalk--
the capacity of
the network depends
on how much overlap there is
between our stored pattern
and all the other patterns
in the network, all right?
So if all the memories
are orthogonal,
if all the patterns
then they're all
stable attractors.
But if one of those memories,
xi 1-- let's take xi 1--
is close to xi 0,
then xi 0 dot xi 1--
the two patterns
are very similar--
then the dot product is
going to be N, right?
And when you plug
that, if that's N,
then you can see that this
becomes xi 1 i, right?
So what happens is that
these other memories that
are similar to our
memorized pattern--
then when you sum that,
when you compute that sum,
some of these terms
get big enough so
that the memory in the next
step is not that stored memory.
It's a combination.
All right?
So what happens is-- so the
way the capacity of the network
is stored.
So you can't actually choose all
your memories to be orthogonal.
But a pretty good way of making
memory is nearly orthogonal
is to store them as
random [AUDIO OUT]..
So a lot of the
thinking that goes
into how you would
build a network that
stores a lot of patterns
is to take your memories
and sort of convert them in a
way that makes them maximally
orthogonal to each other.
You can use things
like lateral inhibition
to orthogonalize
different inputs.
So once you make your
patterns sort of noisy,
then it turns out
you can actually
calculate that if
the values of xi
sort of look like
random numbers,
that you can store
up to about 15%
of the number of neurons worth
of memories in your network.
So if I have 100
neurons in my network,
I should be able to store
about 15 different states
in that network
before they start
to interfere with each other,
before you have a sufficiently
high probability that
two of those memories
are next to each other.
And as soon as that
happens, then you
start getting crosstalk
between those memories that
causes the state of
the system to evolve
in a way that doesn't recall
one of your stored memories,
all right?
And what that looks like
in the energy landscape
is when you build a network
with, let's say, five memories,
there will be five minima in
the network that sort of have
equal low values of energy.
But when you start sticking too
many memories in your network,
you end up with what are called
spurious attractors, sort
of local minima
that aren't at the--
that don't correspond to
one of the stored memories.
And so as the system evolves,
it can be going downhill
and get stuck in one
of those minima that
look like a combination of
two of the stored memories.
And that's what went wrong here
with the guy with the penguin
sticking out of his head.
Who knows?
Maybe that's what happens
when you look at something
and you're confused
about what youre seeing.
We don't know if that's
actually what happens,
but it would be an
interesting thing to test.
Any questions?
All right, so that's--
so you can see that these
are long-term memories.
These don't depend on activity
in the network to store, right?
Those are programmed into
the synaptic connections
between the neurons.
So you can shut off
all the activity.
And if you just put in up
a pattern of input that
reminds you of
something, the network
will recover the
full memory for you.